bonjour à tous merci de me retrouver sur
public sénat à suivre cet après-midi sur
notre antenne les travaux de la
commission d' enquête sur le coût réel
de l'électricité
cet après midi les sénateurs
auditionnent andré claude lacoste c'est
le président de l'asn l'autorité de
sûreté nucléaire
cette autorité avait rendu un rapport
début janvier dans lequel il était
stipulé que les centrales françaises
avaient un niveau de sûreté suffisant
mais qu'il fallait investir des
milliards d'euros pour renforcer leur
robustesse alors ces investissements
vont ils avoir un impact sur le coût de
l'électricité
éléments de réponse avec cette audition
bien mes chers collègues nous allons
démarrer si vous voulez bien monsieur le
président de l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire je vous remercie beaucoup
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation
cela dit vous n'aviez pas le choix je
crois qu'on a un peu obligé de répondre
aux invitations des commissions d
enquête parlementaire
mais je vous remercie d'être là
aujourd'hui nous sommes exactement à
mi-chemin de toutes les auditions alors
petit rappel de la raison pour laquelle
vous êtes ici monsieur président cette
commission denquête était une demande du
groupe écologie du
du sénat le bureau a accepté cette
demande et donc elle a été créée le
rapporteur on est monsieur jean
desessard j'en ai été nommé un président
et je vais vous demander de respecter un
petit peu la tradition en la matière
c'est à dire que je vais vous demander
de prêter serment
je vais vous demander de dire toute la
vérité rien que la vérité et je vais
enfin vous demander de lever la main
droite et de dire je le jure le jure je
vous en remercie alors pour faciliter
votre audition disions pour la rendre
pour entrer plus vivement dans le débat
notre rapporteur jean desessard vous
envoyez à l'avance un certain nombre de
questions de manière à ce que vous
puissiez les préparer il est bien
évident que dans cette mission d'
enquête sur les problèmes du coût de
l'énergie du prix de l'énergie
toute la mission que vous avez rempli
sur l'après fukushima est le résultat de
votre mission
des travaux nécessaires à faire dans
l'eau 59 centrales nucléaires et le
sujet qui nous intéresse de loin le plus
notre rapporteur va vous rappeler ces
questions parce que c'est important
qu'elles figurent au procès verbal et
ensuite vous y répondez à priori dans
l'ordre sauf si ça vous semble pour nous
éclaircir plus intéressant de d'inverser
n'hésitez pas à le faire
monsieur le rapporteur à vous la parole
merci président donc monsieur la cause
de nous avons adressé cinq questions la
première pouvez vous faire un point sur
le chantier de le p r de flamanville et
notamment sur ses conséquences
financières pour la production
d'électricité à partir de paix m seconde
question à quel moment peut-on évaluer
le coût des travaux de sûreté post
fukushima
pouvez-vous commenter cet égard le choix
fait par le gouvernement de surévaluer
de 3 euros le prix de l'arenh estimé par
la commission champsaur
troisième question commenté des
conclusions du rapport de la cour des
comptes de janvier 2012
concernant les charges futures y compris
le mécanisme de couverture d'une partie
de ses charges par des actifs dédiés les
sites prévus
un projet au le stockage des déchets
vous pas resté insuffisant en termes de
dimensions dimensionnement quatrième
question pouvez vous commenter le régime
actuel de responsabilité civile en cas
d'accident nucléaire ainsi que les
dispositions contenues à cet égard dans
le projet de loi numéro 4 181 2011 2012
déposé au sénat le 21 mars 2012
les différents risques liés à
l'exploitation de centrales nucléaires y
compris ceux liés à un accident majeur
peuvent-ils être couvert par un système
de type assurantielle le corps dit pas
créée en 2005 pour définir une gestion
des conséquences d'un accident nucléaire
et tu dit il la question du coût
financier d'un tel accident est
cinquième et dernière question sur le
plan stratégique
comment peut-on concilier la nécessité
de planifier longtemps à l'avance le
remplacement de centrales nucléaires
avec les incertitudes sur la durée de
vie de ses centrales
celle-ci découlant aussi bien du
principe des visites décennales qui peut
conduire
l'asn à interdire la poursuite de
l'exploitation que du manque
d'expérience concrète sur le
vieillissement des centrales nucléaires
au-delà de l'âge de 30 ans en france
voilà monsieur frais dans les cinq
questions nous avons adressé reçu la
cote monsieur le président je vous
laisse la parole vous nous laissez quand
même un petit temps de questions
réponses à la fin de votre exposé en
réponse à ces cinq questions je vous en
remercie mais merci monsieur bélanger du
compte pas vous la base vous redire avec
un exposé d'une heure d'abord sur l'
invitation que m'avait faite de
d'intervenir devant vaud c'est tout à
fait important pour une institution
comme l'autorité sûreté nucléaire
autorités ingrates yves indépendante de
teura porter devant le parlement et ses
différentes manifestations
autorité indépendante nous ne rapportons
pas dans le gouvernement mais nous
considérons que nous rapportons devant
le parlement
les rapports privilégiés à l'évidence
avec l'office parlementaire des choix
scientifiques et technologiques mais
très régulièrement
nous sommes là mais à intervenir ils
nous considérons que c'est en même temps
un honneur un devoir et une pratique
normale
sur les différentes questions ce que
vous avez posé je commencerai par dire
que la scène à deux grands types
d'activités nous contrôlerons d'une part
la sûreté et la radioprotection sur des
choses que j'appelle des grosses bêtes
150 grosses bêtes dont les réacteurs
d'edf dont les installations de la hague
dont directeur recherche et puis l'avant
par ailleurs une autre activité qui
n'est pas dans le champ aujourd'hui mais
qui est fondamental pour nous c'est ce
que l'aplomb du caire de proximité nous
contrôlons l'utilisation des sources
radioactives dans beaucoup de domaines
industrie recherche et surtout médecine
est actuellement 1 aux objets principaux
et la radioprotection des patients
sujets qui a été initiée par les
accidents qui sont survenus à epinal et
sujet de long terme qui est la
croissance des doses reçues par les
patients en matière de radiographie je
dis simplement un mot je vais pas dire
que les surveillants des grosses bêtes
n'est qu'un de nos deux axes de travail
alors j'en viens maintenant aux cinq
questions vous avez posé en commençant
par que père et en suivant les questions
dans l'ordre où ils avaient énoncé que
ppr est le premier réacteur de puissance
construit en france depuis longtemps n'a
pas été construit à claude puissance en
france depuis les réacteurs de choses et
de civaux ça veut dire qu'il ya une
interruption de construction pendant
pratiquement une vingtaine d'années
alors nous contrôlons de près la
construction du recteur p r nous avons
commencé à contrôler cette construction
d'hier et avant même que le chantier a
débuté
il faut se souvenir que la conception du
réacteur père au début des années 90 est
le résultat d'une prise de position
d'autorité sûreté nucléaire à l'époque
mon prédécesseur en 91 a écrit edf au
cea et à framatome qu' il n'était plus
question de construire en france des
réacteurs du type n 4 qu'il fallait pas
ses générations futures tirant les
conséquences de tchernobyl
et c'est cette prise de position de
l'asn qui entraînait l'étude des options
sûreté
d'un réacteur plus sûre sur hector
d'abord été franco-français et ensuite
été franco allemand c'est à dire que
pendant les années qui ont suivi 90
l'ensemble des acteurs français allemand
on travaille ensemble
je me souviens en particulier de prises
de position unique que dans une prison
que légalement et moi en anglais sur les
principaux passages de sûreté de l'état
opère nous connaissions opère depuis
longtemps
c'est le résultat d'un certain nombre
d'imposition que nous l'avons fait à
l'époque alors j'en viens à la
construction nous surveillons de près la
construction depuis le début la
construction nous avons opéré plus d'une
centaine d'inspection sur le chantier et
nous avons opéré une cinquantaine
d'inspection l'ex dans les services
centraux d'edf
chez les fournisseurs chez les sous
traitants donc nous suivrons de très
près cette construction à quoi nous nous
attendions nous depuis le départ nous
attendions à ce que hier sur les
difficultés nées de la nécessité de re
apprendre ce que c'est que la
construction des réacteurs de puissance
je me souviens d'avoir été invité à
participer à une réunion organisée par
nos homologues américains les
commissaires de la nuclear regulatory
commission
quelques années et nos homologues
avaient réuni les chefs d' autorité
sûreté de france de finlande au japon et
de taïwan et j'avais été menés à l'heure
dite il pose la question si on
recommence à compteur l'acteur de
puissance ou des états unis
quels conseils vous à nous donner pour
se payer tu devrais dire le problème est
celui du rpt learning
comment réapprendre à construire comme
on va prendre à surveiller la
construction d'un lecteur nous avons et
le nous c'est pas seulement l'autorité
de sûreté c'est edf et ses
sous-traitants
oubliez ce que nous chacun dans notre
domaine avions l'habitude de faire et
donc ce qu'on retrouve c'est exactement
ceci quand
oui à des difficultés à mettre
correctement en oeuvre de béton bas
c'est clairement un manque d'habitude la
qualité nucléaire quand nous arrêtons la
construction le tel ou tel élément d'un
pressuriseur fabrique t en italie par
une filiale de groupe pour le compte
d'areva s'est clairement sous traitants
ne s'est pas mis en mesure de respecter
les normes de qualité et les normes de
sûreté du nucléaire est tout à fait
évident que l'épisode le plus récent qui
vient d'intervenir en et puis l'autre
touchant pont polaire est un épisode de
manque de qualité tout à fait flagrant
autrement dit on se trouve face à un
manque d'habitude de la construction
alors ça se traduit parfois par des
choses qui se rattrape facilement ce
sera ça se traduit parfois par des
choses qui impose d'autre part un arrêt
du chantier on a déjà été par deux fois
deux chantiers pour des motifs de
bétonnage ça se traduit par les retards
concept df lui-même qui constatent les
défauts mais c'est clairement un
processus de ré apprentissage qui n'est
pas étonnant mais qui est très frappant
quand on le regarde
alors chacun peut nourrir l'espoir que
c'est un processus d'apprentissage qui
pourrait servir si de nouveaux réacteurs
au pays a été construit en france où le
moment mais il est clair que c'est un
processus extrêmement prégnant
extrêmement important sur ce premier
point je n'en tiens là quitte à répandre
la question si vous le permettez
le deuxième point c'est celui du montant
des travaux de sûreté post fukushima
alors clairement post fukushima est un
évènement majeur comme tchernobyl comme
free malendure à un post fukushima
comme il ya eu un post it après
fukushima même chose que pour tchernobyl
et three mile island et a clairement
beaucoup de choses à en retirer
avec une difficulté c'est classique sur
ce genre d'événement majeur c'est que
la compréhension complète du phénomène
peut prendre très longtemps j'ai
souvenir que la prime island il avait
fallu six ans pour être sûr que le coeur
du réacteur avait fondu et dans
l'intervalle des papiers scientifiques
avaient dit que le coeur du réacteur
n'avait pas fondu le sentiment qu
exprime une autorité sûreté nucléaire
c'est qu'ils peuvent valoir jusqu'à dix
ans pourra totalement sûr d'avoir
compris fukushima et ça nous met donc
dans une situation où à l'évidence il
faut tirer un certain nombre conséquent
de fukushima celle qui nous paraissent
les plus évidentes il n'est pas exclu
que au fil du temps au fil de la
compréhension plus fine des phénomènes
nous soyons amenés à revenir en arrière
et à dire telle ou telle prescription
nous avons prises n'étaient pas fondées
alors c'est très inconfortable sur le
plan intellectuel
ça peut être très coûteux mais je pense
qu'il faut être clair c'est quelque
chose qui fait partie du paysage
alors toujours est il qu'il est apparu
rapidement qu'il y avait un certain
nombre de conséquences à tirer de
fukushima ses conséquences ont compris
deux formes les stress tests au niveau
européen et l'élévation complémentaires
sur tel ou français le conseil européen
des 24 et 25 mars 2011 a décidé de
lancer de stress tests et le premier
ministre françois fillon nous l'avait
écrit quelques jours avant pour nous
demander de lancer des évaluations
complémentaires de sûreté alors un club
de chefs d'autorité qui s'appelle
moindres avaient anticipé de l'avion
commençait rédiger un cahier des charges
et décharges été approuvé et le
processus reste est l'évaluation
complémentaire de sûreté a été lancé au
niveau européen était il a été lancé sur
les seuls réacteurs de puissance au
niveau français blancs ont décidé de
l'étendre audio français évasion
complémenter assure t on portait à la
fois sur les incas puissance et sur
l'ensemble des installations concernées
par fukushima se mirent en particulier
l'installation comportant des piscines
avec du combustible usé donc je vais
porter évaluation d'un premier temps non
pas sur les 59 réacteurs de puissance
mais sur 80 installations
quand j 50 infractions surpuissant
c'est-à-dire fait porter les évasions
complément sûreté aussi bien que 58
réacteurs en fout
demant que sur le réacteur epr à
flamanville et puis deuxième extension
finalement des sites en france
c'est de donner un poids particulier à
tout ce qui est facteurs sociaux humains
et quand relationnel
nous avons fait parce que ça nous
paraissait tout à fait fondés et nous
l'avons fait à la demande d'un certain
nombre de parties prenantes dont très
clairement les syndicats n'ont pas
encore traité ce sujet facteurs sociaux
et humains obsessionnelle mais il est
clair qu'à nos yeux que c'est un point
tout à fait important alors nous avons
lancé le processus en france en
demandant à rapport aux exploitants en
réponse un thé des charges dont j'ai dit
qu'il avait été élaboré au niveau
européen rapporte exploitants été fourni
en septembre n'ont fait analyser par
notre expert technique tirer c'est nous
l'avons fait analyser par nouveau
permanent d'experts et avec une très
large ouverture expertise la réunion des
groupes permanents a réuni plus de 200
personnes pendant trois jours et nous
avons demandé l'avis d'experts français
et étrangers la vie de cette association
environnementale très large
participation
ça nous a conduit à une prise de
position que nous avons rendu public le
3 janvier le 3 janvier j'ai remis mon
rapport au premier ministre à 11 heures
et il nous l'avons tenu une conférence
de presse en début d'après-midi alors
que résiste-t-il de cette prise de
position de l'asn
il résulte un certain nombre de prises
de position ils sont les prises de
position de principe que nous la tâche
ont maintenant à traduire en décisions
juridiquement opposable au principal
pour les réacteurs de puissance trois
choses un noyau dur d'un concept a été
proposé par edf mise en forme par l'irsn
et qui consiste à dire que dans une
installation de verre et en partie d'une
centrale il ya une partie qui doit
encore mieux résisté que le reste aux
agressions externes
ça vise en particulier un centre de
gestion de crise vous devez risée et un
diesel d'ultime secours bunkeriser mais
en particulier deuxième sujet la force
d'action ou d'intervention rapide
proposés par edf
ça nous paraît une bonne idée dire la
capacité de projeter sur un site
ou un accident grave interviendrait se
projeter en même temps des personnes
compétentes et du matériel
supplémentaire
et puis troisième point des études de
faisabilité de dispositifs
supplémentaires de protection de l'eau
souterraine en cas d'accident grave
c'est un sujet plus délicat
techniquement mais que nous paraît
s'imposer
alors ça c'est ce que nous avons indiqué
être toute prise de position c'est ce
que nous traduisons nous l'allons
traduire en codécision nous avons
préparé des projets décision la doite
transparence et sécurité en matière
nucléaire de l'impôt de conduite edf
on a consulté edf certains d'ailleurs
nous l'avions nous connaît la scène une
audition d'edf sur ces sujets à en
prendre une décision d'ici d'ici le mois
de juin alors par définition les
décisions précises sont pas encore prise
nous attendons les observations de f et
puis nous prendrons toute autre position
sur les coûts résultant de ceux ci nous
disposons d'une évaluation sommaire qui
a été avancé par edf et qui consiste à
dire que le coût de l'ensemble des
mesures que nous imposerons sans doute
je voyais encore une fois décisions ne
sont pas prises
le détail n'est pas connue c'est donc
une évolution très sommaire est de
l'ordre de 10 milliards d'euros
n'avons pas d'élément permettant de
mettre en doute les sommes qui nous
parle je dirais que sommes-nous assez
vraisemblable compte tenu de ce qu'on
prend savoir des différents éléments
cause voilà sur ce point le troisième la
traîne question qui nous est posée
concerne les conclusions du rapport la
cour des comptes rendu public en janvier
alors sur ce point là je dois d'abord
commencé par dire que nous avons
travaillé très étroite en liaison avec
la cour des comptes
nous avons été auditionnés par la cour
des comptes
nous avons fourni à son élément lave ont
répondu à son projet d'observation et et
nous y avons répondu d'autant plus
volontiers que l'avion le sentiment de
la cour des comptes faisait un travail
de fond qui était depuis longtemps
nécessaire parce que nous nous trouvons
effectivement en france face à un
certain nombre de charges et de coûts
importants qu'il s'agisse du
démantèlement qu'il s'agisse la gestion
du déchet il s'agit de provisionnement
qui à nos yeux ont fait l'objet d'études
que relativement imparfaite ou ou
incertaines ou une grossière et il est
mon sentiment que je suis en somme le
sujet la cour des comptes a porté sa
capacité d'investigation et son
expertise et donc je dirais que nous
partageons très largement l'ensemble des
conclusions de la cour des comptes
une éclosion importante c'est qu'il n'y
a pas de coups masqué mais il est conclu
importante c'est que c'est un somme de
coûts dont il faudrait sûrement préciser
le montant
un des points étant en particulier le
coût du futur stockage de bure s'il est
autorisé qui est clairement la dépense
la plus massive dans le champ mais il
faut également préciser le coût du
démantèlement il ya trop de choses ce
genre précisé il ya très sûrement
matière investigations
j'ajoute que un des points qui nous
paraissent les plus importants et celui
de la couverture financière des charges
futures
c'est un pas que l'avion déjà relevé sur
lesquels nous étions déjà manifestés et
qui aurait qu elle la cour a insisté la
loi du 28 juin 2006 soit gestion déchets
est tout à fait clair ces demandes que
les provisions pour l'ensemble des
charges d'avenir soit gagée par des
actifs qui soit suffisamment sûre et
suffisamment liquide et nous voyons
comme quelque chose d'anormal comme une
façon de tourner la loi le fait que très
régulièrement
le gouvernement s'attache à contourner
les dispositions de cette loi en
permettant que parmi les gages de ses
provisions figurent des les actions de
filiales où figurent même des
engagements de l'état dont on sait
malheureusement parfois ce qu'ils valent
encore une fois la loi disait tout à
fait clairement il faut des actifs
devrait d'actifs mobilisables et sur le
quatrième point que vous avez soulevé
concerne les l'accident nucléaire
alors là je commençais par une
affirmation qui est une infirmation
constante de la scène depuis qu'elle a
été créée c'est que personne ne peut
garantir qu'il n'y aura jamais
d'accident nucléaire en france
on peut le dire sous une deuxième forme
on peut le dire que un accident en
france ne peut jamais être exclue on
peut le dire qu une troisième forme
l'improbable est possible mais que toute
façon ça conduit au fait que personne ne
peut garantir qu'il n'y aura jamais
d'accident nucléaire en france
à plus forte raison personne ne peut-il
garantir qu'il n'y aura jamais
d'accident nucléaire en europe
donc c'est quelque chose dont il faut
tenir compte lors nous de notre côté là
ont tenu compte de deux façons
premièrement en multipliant l'exercice
de sûreté nucléaire nous menons 10 à 12
par an mais s'ils ont mobilisé autant
que possible l'ensemble des parties
prenantes en y associant quand c'est
possible des exercices d'évacuation même
la portée limitée
et puis une deuxième façon pour nous de
manifester souci a été de réfléchir
autre post accidentelle nous avons
demandé au premier ministre en 2005
willy pas fière de nous confier une
mission de réflexion sur le post
accidentelle dire la gestion de tout ce
qui suit un accident c'est à dire la
gestion elle des populations
éventuellement évacuer la gestion des
territoires la gestion des récoltes la
gestion du bâti la gestion de l'eau
c'est une infection extrêmement
difficile à ma connaissance nous
la france est le seul pays où cette
réflexion est menée avec ton extrêmement
difficile nous allons obtenu deux
colloques internationaux donc
prochainement publier un rapport
proposant des mesures au gouvernement
mais le fait que
nous ayons dans cette attitude façon
parfaitement publiques 3 400 personnes y
participent montre bien que pour nous la
possibilité d'un accident nucléaire est
tout à fait présente donc dans le champ
voilà ce que je souhaitais dire qu
initialement alors deuxième point c'est
le coût d'un accident nucléaire je crois
qu'il faut vraiment se faire une idée de
ce que c'est que le coût possible un
accident nucléaire
il ya quelques estimations préliminaires
de l'irsn qui montrait que pour un
accident modérer le coût moyen pouvait
être de 70 milliards d'euros et le coût
estimé l'accident de fukushima ou de
tchernobyl ce n'est pas du tout du tout
facile compte tenu du fait qu'il s'agit
de chiffres et des dommages causés à des
populations avec mort ou 100 morts la
première chiffré vous le fait d'avoir
évacué un territoire d'abriter des
personnes mais l'ordre de grandeur et
provenant de 600 milliards à 1000
milliards d'euros alors de façon
confirmé ses estimations nous avons
essayé de passer commande une étude à ce
sujet en novembre dernier
personne n'a soumissionné pour faire
cette étude
et ça peut pas renvoyer à quelque chose
avec l'état quelque chose d'important
dire que sur interne le sujet il n'y a
pas de terreau de compétences ou de
laboratoires ou de centres d'études
nécessaires pour se lancer dans les
études nécessaires contre il ya scène a
commencé à le faire mais je crois qu'il
est tout à fait importante que des
études soient développées si possible
d'ailleurs d'études contradictoires
indépendante pour que le début d'un
débat qu'est ce que c'est que le coût
d'un accident nucléaire
la responsabilité du client si vite
qu'est ce que ça veut dire est il
possible d'imaginer de couvrir sa part
l'assurance est ce que ça a un sens
facilement ton de ce genre avec jean
kith l'avenir de l'étude il ya dix jours
à washington où il doit participer
un séminaire annuel s'était jeu à
washington j'ai été très frappée de voir
qu'un économiste fondamentalement
libéral finissez sa présentation feu
d'accident nucléaire en dix ans il ya un
niveau de risque d'accident nucléaire ou
seul l'état s'y est assez fort et
puissant peut il finit ce se mettre en
face du risque et on voit bien que ces
récents comme fukushima survenue en
slovénie mais l'état slovène n'y
résisterait pas alors par rapport à ça
c'est le problème des montants plafonds
de responsabilité et nucléaire c'est
vilain qui figure la question est un
problème qui est important mais c'est
pas le problème majeur est tout à fait
clair que nous considérons comme une
bonne chose que le gouvernement a déposé
un projet de loi au sénat qui tend à
porter le plafond de la responsabilité
il est patent nucléaire de 91,5 millions
d'euros à 700 millions d'euros
mais voyez que ça ne couvre qu'une
partie du champ ça couvre la partie
passe du chant et encore une fois on
sent que lyon mais c'est un peu la même
conclusion savait que celle que que
j'avais sur les sujets démantèlement il
je pense que tout à fait matière à un
certain nombre d'études
d'abord sans doute peu cohérente et plus
qui peut un peu par des bap peuvent
converger et puis la direction vous
poser est celle la planification de la
durée de fonctionnement des centrales et
la politique énergétique leur prêtera
mots de vocabulaire mais qui n'est pas
innocent nous abstenons de parler de
durée de vie des centrales
nous parlons durée de fonctionnement ce
que pour nous à durée de vie c'est
l'ensemble durée de construction plus
durée de fonctionnement plus dur et
démantèlement donc nous parlons de deux
durée de fonctionnement
alors quelle est la règle en france
quand une autorisation est donnée
l'autorisation est donnée sans
limitation dans le temps imitation
explicite dans le temps l'autorisation
est donnée tant que l'installation peut
être considéré comme sûr et le fait que
l'installation est sûrs et vérifiés
j'irai au jour le jour par une
inspection que nous pratiquons
nous pratiquons me l'inspection par an
sur les installations nucléaires
mille par an sûrement sur l'ensemble
dont plus de la moitié sur edf
oui que 250 500 sur edf et donc nous
pratiquons d'inspection au jour le jour
nous réjouissons quand il ya un incident
en accident nous faisons du retour
d'expérience quand on apprend quelque
chose à l étranger ça veut dire et c'est
au jour le jour
puis il rendez vous plus solennelle sous
forme de règlement sûreté périodique
tous les dix ans on appelle souvent sa
visite décennale
selon dire tous les dix ans nous
vérifions deux choses nous vérifions si
l'installation est conforme son
référentiel donc est ce que
l'information et conformerai qui
s'applique à elle dont nous vérifions si
tel ou tel composant a vieilli nous
vérifions s'il n'ya pas tel ou tel
défaut qui apparaît dans le béton nous
vérifions si la vérification de
conformité et puis nous faisons par
ailleurs une réévaluation de sûreté
séduisant ben voilà installations telle
qu'elle est
comment se compare-t-elle à des
installations plus récentes et plus sûrs
et donc tout demandons à l'exploitant
d'essayer de faire progresser la sûreté
en exploitation au regard de référence
plus récentes
je prends avec l'amp type xv est un
acteur 900 mégawatts
tous les dix ans nous demandons qu
est-ce qui parmi les objectifs sûreté du
réacteur européenne peut être appliquée
raisonnablement à ce réacteur
douai d'objectifs conformité et
révolution sûreté ça veut donc dire
savait que nous pouvons être amenés à
prendre la décision de fermer un acteur
aussi bien tous les dix ans de façon un
peu solennel ou en disant au bout de dix
ans va vraiment nous ne voyons pas
continuer plus de cinq ans mais nous
pouvons prendre au jour le jour est une
des caractéristiques du parc français
sait qui est extrêmement sans d'arrivée
alors l'avantagé d'un parc standardisé
et claire
d'abord yeux il est économique ça ça
concerne essentiellement edf
et puis deuxièmement chaque fois qu'on
trouve quelque chose à améliorer chaque
fois que du retour je pense à faire on
peut l'appliquer ensemble des réacteurs
et donc améliorer sûreté du parc
la contrepartie c'est qu'on peut se
trouver un jour face à un incident ou un
pépin ou un défaut grave affectant
l'ensemble du parc et à ce moment là la
nation se trouve dans un état difficile
que je caractériserais par quelque chose
qui illustre bien notre peau le
président de l'autorité de sûreté
nucléaire allant voir ce qu en suivant
l'air du temps présent république ou le
premier ministre et lui disant tout et
là il ya un choix que je ne peux pas
faire
il s'agit de savoir si on coupe
l'électricité ou si on accepte que les
réacteurs fonctionnent en est à sûreté
dégradés dont nous faisons tout pour
éviter qu'il en soit ainsi
chaque fois qu'on trouve un défaut nous
demandons c'est générique on essaie de
prévenir mais ça veut donc dire c'est
que il y a la possibilité que les
installations soient traités de façon
unitaire ou collectives à tout moment et
en particulier à l'occasion des
dérèglements décennaux tout ceci n'a de
sens que si on peut faire fonctionner la
mécanique comme je viens de dire que si
il ya une politique énergétique
suffisante pour permettre effectivement
d'éviter un conflit entre sûreté
nucléaire et sécurité énergétique et
notre souci est bien celui là nous avons
par moment le sentiment que faute
d'investir dans de nouvelles capacités
de production et peu nous importe que ce
soit nucléaire ou autre faute d'
investir de nouvelles capacités de
production
la france risque de se trouver une
situation où il peut y avoir un conflit
entre le maintien en fonctionnement
d'une partie du parc nucléaire et
l'approvisionnement l'approvisionnement
français l'heure nous ne disons que nous
craignons qu'un complice le gens
arrivent c'est la cour des comptes va
plus loin elle dit que d'ores et déjà et
à une décision implicite de prolongation
de la durée de fonctionnement du parc
nucléaire faute de capacité alternative
mais c'est clairement pour nous un souci
important et et voyez bien que le poids
pour nous c'est que
le rendez-vous des dix ans est solennel
eloi d'épuiser le nombre d occasions où
nous pouvons être amenés à dire cette
telle ou telle centrale à vocation
affirmée
voilà monsieur le président de façon
sommaire un premier round de réponses à
vos questions
sa mère est précisé monsieur le
président je remercie moi j'ai quatre
questions très précises et cote à vous
demander mais avant je voudrais demander
aux rapporteurs s'il a eu réponse à ces
questions s'il a besoin d'un complément
de précisions les deux présidents
messieurs la colle ça mon tour je vous
remercie pour la précision et même la
franchise de vos réponses et vous avez
marqué et moi ce qui me retient donc
c'est vous avez répondu assez
précisément question mais vous avez mis
le dos vous avez parlé de d'être à
certains moments inconfortable
intellectuellement
alors je retiens ce mot dans le sens que
j'imagine pour plusieurs trois exemples
enfin pas trois exemples des trois
précisions que je demande le matériel
pour inspecter le
les endroits sensibles où on ne peut pas
accéder j'ai vu d'un petit film
effectivement vos inspecteurs je crois à
la brune et lisse et regarder les sacs
qui était chargée pour les déchets on
leur demandait ce qu'il soit refait donc
ça allait trouver ça très bien mais vous
pouvez pas voir la même démarche que
vous allez dans la cuve donc qui est
garant du matériel que vous mettez du
contrôle
est-ce que c'est fait par edf donc à
sont là qu'elle ait des disons la marge
d'autonomie que vous avez pour un
contrôle technique dans les endroits
inaccessibles en dire j'avais ces
besoins de ces questions la deuxième
question là ce que vous dites
après fukushima nous avons des des
choses nouvelles avoir été compris vous
dit on mais il nous faut au moins des
fois cinq ou six années pour bien
comprendre mais est-ce que ça fait pas
drôle pour drôle été mal utilisées mais
est-ce que ça pose pas beaucoup de
questions de voir que des choses que
vous croyez avoir résolu qu'en tant
qu'autorité de sûreté bien se montre que
dans ce qui se passe c'est des choses
imprévisibles qui alors est-ce que
qu'elle fasse je sais pas quel est le la
méthode que vous avez par rapport à des
choses nouvelles qui arrivent que vous
n'aviez pas prévu et par rapport à
l'avenir de d à ce que cela peut se
faire comment qu'en est il et je relis
ça votre dernière interrogation et je
vous en remercie de l'avoir opposé aussi
franchement vous avez dire au bout d'un
moment s'il n'y a pas là
être sûr que au niveau énergétique on
est suffisamment la sécurité énergétique
vous avez employé ce moment là et bien
on ne sera plus ou moins poussé on va
dire ou inciter ou à dire que ma foi
c'est il faut quand même continuer
l'exploitation alors c je vous remercie
de cette franchise parce que souvent
quand on demande aux gens mais faut-il
poursuivre la durée de vie donc
seulement enfin la durée de
fonctionnement et nous disent mais il ya
l'autorité de sûreté nucléaire et vous
aujourd'hui vous dites oui mais nous
aussi on est soumis
non pas que technique pas s'il ya
vraiment quelque chose qui va pas et
vous dites vous pouvez de soumis un
choix qu'il devrait normalement part
élevée de votre fonction et que vous
êtes amené à choisir parfois entre la
sécurité énergétique et une haute
sécurité nucléaire fin j'ai cru
comprendre ça donc c'était pour définir
un petit peu mieux cette notion d'un
confortable intellectuellement dans
lequel vous situez merci monsieur
rapporte auriez pas de question je crois
monsieur le président merci monsieur
pédant d'abord sur la première question
c'est comment vérifier l'état du
matériel ou l'état de l'installation et
à la centrale dans des endroits
sensibles alors il ya un premier point
sur lequel il faut être clair c'est un
principe fondamental de la sûreté
nucléaire
il est exprimé dans l'est dans les
certificats mental de naira il est
exprimé dans la loi tsn le premier
responsable assure tessa centre de la
centrale c'est edf et si l'exploitant
est considérée globalement comme non
fiable c'est extrêmement clair on doit
lui retirer sa licence d'exploitation
c'est tout à fait clair donc je dirais
est tout à fait normal que au premier
degré ce soit edf qui est à charge de
vérifier l'état des installations du rif
y étale son matériel de faire l'ensemble
des mesures nous nous avons des moyens
de vérification la voie des moyens de
vérification avec l'assistance technique
de l'irsn nous pouvons faire appel à des
tierces parties
je prends un exemple le bétonnage
de flamanville 3 nous nous sommes pas
directement expert en bétonnage il y à
l'airé scène des gens compétents auquel
on a fait appel
donc nous ne sommes pas dépourvus je
prends un autre exemple quand il s'agit
de prendre parti sur la capacité de la
cuve des réacteurs aller au delà 30 ans
il ya un débat sur un certain nombre
d'éléments salue le débat et et et est
nourri par rapport d'une nonne division
spécialisée qui a des visions d'expand
sous pression c'est analyser par un
groupe d'experts dans lesquelles il ya
des experts français et étrangers et que
nous faut dire que vous aimez donc je ne
sens pas dépourvu du point de vue
technique mais encore une fois ceux-ci
ne marche que si nous sommes amenés à
considérer c'est le cas qu'en face de
nous nous avons des exploitants qui sont
dignes d'une certaine confiance passant
du mini certaine confiance
et encore une fois si cette concertée
confiant du spa il ne reste qu'une
solution c'est on enlève la licence
d'exploiter deuxième question vous poser
c'est également une question de fond
n'est-il pas drôle je prends votre
adjectif de constater que nous sommes
amenés à regarder un son d'éléments
nouveaux après fukushima
premier élément c'est je crois que quand
il survient quelque chose comme
fukushima
il faut pas avoir de réflexes d'orgueil
consistant à dire je refuse la regarde
de regarder et chaudes où je refuse de
reconnaître qu'il ya des éléments
nouveaux
quoi l'orgueil extraordinairement
mauvais conseiller sur ce genre de sujet
mettez vous une anecdote il est survenu
récemment un incident que je considère
comme grave en corée du sud
donc la cee'd ans considéré comme d'hab
en corée du sud étaient masquées par
l'opérateur pour un motif qui semble
autant qu'on sache être celui l'honneur
national
c'est intéressant de voir quoi se peut
conduire un concept dévié donc fukushima
est intervenue nous ne sommes pas sûrs
d'avoir tout compris
nous prenons les mesures que nous
paraissait plus immédiate sans s'en fout
d'orgueil lors je prends l'exemple
ensemble de gens non dit le tsunami
faille à trois sujets qui sont étudiées
vient des évaluations complémentaires
sûreté les agressions naturelles tsunami
tremblement de terre
inondations etc deuxième sujet perte
d'alimentation électrique perte de
refroidissement et troisième sujet
gestion tri je vous en dis laisse une
amie c'est pas crédible en europe
réponse dans un pays comme la france
l'équivalent de son ami c'est
l'hypothèse la rupture d'un certain
nombre de barrages consécutif sur des
cours d'eau
nous regardons ça qu'à présent car il
était tellement improbable qu'on ne le
prenait pas en compte sans fausse honte
nous lisons nous faut le prendre en
compte et ainsi de suite mais encore une
fois pas de réaction de faux d'orgueil
il ya des choses à apprendre de
fukushima au moins dans la version
actuelle je continue il peut nous
survenir des choses désagréables sur le
plan intellectuel pour le mans l'accueil
fukushima c'est c'est le tsunami qui a
été plus dévastateurs du tremblement de
terre ne l'a pas être tellement été au
fil du temps on peut apprendre qu'il
n'était pas si encore une fois à nous de
tirer le retour d'expérience aussi aussi
profondément qu'il est possible
encore une fois sans enfant sont pros
spiller sans fausse honte et c'est la
même chose que font nos collègues
étrangers dans le troisième point c'est
que vous avez cassé la sécurité
énergétique c'est tout à fait clair que
pour nous le sujet que j'ai abordé que
vous avez au prix est un sujet
fondamental
il ya simplement un point sur lequel je
corrige après ce que vous avez dit si un
jour il y avait un conflit latent entre
eux le maintien en fonctionnement de
réacteurs qui ne seraient pas
suffisamment sur un non-lieu et
l'approvisionnement en électricité de la
france est tout à fait clair que c'est
pas d'autorité sûreté qui prendrait
partie se trouve trop capital's mais
c'est pas à nous de prendre l'ensemble
des décisions pour le bonheur du monde
je pense que nous apporterions quant au
premier ministre présent à public et mon
sentiment c'est que c'est typiquement un
sujet sur lequel c'est soit plus haut
niveau de l'exécutif soit au parlement
dont font partie mais l'évidence mais il
ya des limites à la responsabilité que
que de pouvons que nous pouvons prendre
les cibles du président j'ai quelques
questions ensuite madame rossignol
monsieur dantec madame chercher
peut-être d'autres ensuite
proment et jean-claude très bien mais
j'avais plein temps excuse moi jean todt
n'avait pas vu première question
concernant je vous ai bien entendu sur
le ce que vous avez dit à propos de vos
contrôles pas des semaines d'essai nommé
vos contrôles inopinés il y a
régulièrement des incidents sur nos
centrales
comment est ce que l'asn intervient
parce que les incidents sont graduée de
1 à 7
je crois un c'est tout petit incident
est ce que même lors des incidents
un systématiquement dsm va sur place
soit physiquement soit plus tard
deuxième question vous avez à propos des
provisions vous avez dit les fait qu'edf
est gagé ses provisions sur des
actualités eux ça ne sont pas des vrais
actifs je veux bien que vous précisiez
votre pensée c'est un jugement que vous
portez là dessus pourquoi pourquoi
avez-vous troisième question mais
permettez vous j'ai passé une partie de
votre question vous avez dit que le fait
que edf pour ses provisions est gagé les
actions d rt eux ça n'était pas des
vrais actifs kg donc j'aimerais que vous
nous préciser un petit peu votre pensée
derrière cela
troisième question concernant votre
mission que vous avez fait rapidement
auprès des 19 rapidement pardon
efficacement vous avez rapidement rempli
votre mission
des travaux nécessaires travaux de
sûreté nécessaire post-fukushima
vous estimez 18 milliards j'ai beaucoup
aimé votre un été en disant estimation
sommaire et notamment vous avez dit pour
deux raisons il n'est pas impossible que
ça bouge mais à mon avis ça peut bouger
quand la hausse en fonction des réponses
que vous donnera l'exploitant sur
l'ensemble des oeuvres aux observations
ça risque d'augmenter un petit peu et
puis seconde augmentation qui sera pas
immédiate mais qui risque de s'étendre
dans le temps c'est ce que j'appelle le
retour d'expérience vous avez bien dit
que fukushima va probablement encore
bouge
enfin nous tirons des leçons de ce qui
s'est passé là-bas pendant non pas six
ans comme inscrit mile island mais
peut-être plus souvent là j'aimerais
bien un tout petit peu avoir votre
sentiment c'est impossible d'avoir une
estimation mais ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que l'addition risque
d'augmenter au fur et à mesure qu'on en
tirera des leçons
dernière question l'europe là c'est un
j'aimerais un avis de l'autorité que
vous représentez pas
et pour lequel j'ai beaucoup de respect
l'europe à un moment a voulu que ce soit
un leurre niveau qui est le contrôle
post fukushima la france le gouvernement
français est pas le seul a réagi assez
vivement disant écoutez nous savons
prendre nos responsabilités nous avons
une autorité de sûreté en qu'elle nous
avons tout à fait confiance et que nous
considérons comme compétente c'est nous
qui allons faire cette évaluation il
malgré tout j'aimerais avoir votre avis
le entre guillemets avantages
inconvénients parce que je partage
l'avis du gouvernement sur vos
compétences et l'autorité et la manière
indépendante dont vous l'assuré mais
peut-être que ça aurait été utile qui
est un contrôle
peut-être un peu plus européen je pense
pas tellement la france peut dans
certains pays où l'autorité de sûreté
n'a ni vos moyens ni vos compétences
merci monsieur le président je reprends
dans l'ordre les quatre questions que
vous avez posé sur la première les
incidents qui surviennent sur les
centrales alors nous ils ont côté
suivant une échelle qui va qui va en
fait de 0 à 8 heures
pour nous il importe de l'est de les
classer ou de les côtés rapidement nous
lisons l'échelle ines est une chaîne de
communication
c'est pas une échelle technique donc
pour nous il est hors de question
d'attendre trois mois pour classés ex
post en classe aussi vite que possible à
un mot là aussi pour regarder ce qui
s'est passé à fukushima les japonais ont
systématiquement classés l'importance de
l'événement avec retard en commençant
niveau 4 nages qu'au niveau 6 kg au
dernier moment passe à un niveau 7 qui
n'est pas justifiée nous d'emblée dans
la communication d'un essai nous l'avons
dit deux ou trois jours après début de
l'accident
si c'était survenu en france nous
considérerions que c'est plus important
que film résonne moins importants
tchernobyl est d'emblée on a dit vous de
classe sur yon niveau 6 est une fois
vous prenez une décision ce genre vous
êtes beaucoup plus à l'aise pour
communiquer parce que d'anglais vous
avez reconnu que c'est quelque chose qui
est majeure bon c'est simplement une
incidente donc nous veillons à ce que
les exploitants nous nous propose un
classement nous vérifions ce qu'il en
est c'est nous qui in fine et arrêtons
classement
chaque année en france il y à peu près
140 incidents de niveau 1 qui
orientation duclair quelques-uns souhait
transport 101 passes en 45 stations
nucléaires
alors chacun des incidents de niveau 1
fait effectivement l'objet d'inspections
notre part sur les mii inspection à peu
près que j'évoquais il y en a à peu près
20 à 25% qui sont inopinées ou on va
regarder ce qui se passe sans prévenir
d'autres sont thématiques
certaines sont très actives c'est à dire
après un accident
d'autres une inspection de revue dire
qu'on lâche une nuée inspecteurs sur un
site pour garder les choses autrement
toute une gamme mais en particulier
d'instruction réactive après après un
incident je veux que ce jeu en
inspection qui le mène parfois à
reclasser après coup un incident en dix
ans fondamentalement il est plus grave
qui n'avait été vu initialement voilà
sinon je doute que nous avons une façon
d'utiliser le classement de l'échelle
ines qui est considérée à l'étranger
comme ruud nos yeux s'est fondée mais si
rude sur les provisions choqué sur un
certain nombre d'épisodes récent ces
deux choses d'une part le fait que quand
le gouvernement buté sur le fait qu'il
fallait des provisions correspondant aux
à l'esprit de la loi
donc prenez un décret permettant à mes
yeux tourner un peu esprit la loi c'est
typiquement le cas d d d d actions de
rte
et puis par ailleurs il ya des choses
qui me paraissent rigoureusement
contraire la loi soit je prendrai à une
partie des provisions pour démantèlement
du ca se sont transformés en créances
sur l'état
je crois qu'un certain d'entre nous ne
serons pas une et très hot de la valeur
d'une créance sur l'état sur un sujet de
ce genre et nous avons levure
historiquement un certain nombre
d'épisodes où le financement par exemple
du démantèlement de l'installation
nucléaire a été un grand péril faute de
financement parce que c'est un
financement qu'il est rassuré
directement par l'état
c'est ça ce qui nous fait peur
démantèlement est un sujet important un
sujet de long terme
et quand on commence à démantèlement il
faut être sûr de pouvoir le mener
jusqu'à son terme
si on commence à émietter le
démantèlement en épisodes correspondant
au moment où ses finances et il est
clair qu'on se met dans une situation un
très inefficace et deuxièmement
pendables voilà ce que j'avais en tête
une bonne fois l'épisode actions de rte
me paraît moins grave que les pilotes
payants sur l'état mais toute façon
c'est une façon de contourner l'esprit
de la loi
oui mais c'est vraiment vous avez vous
même participé participer au vote de la
loi
j'ai été en tant que fonctionnaire
s'était pas du tout l'esprit doit
l'espérer loi c'était des actifs en tant
que tel et avec josiane fait qu'elle 3e
cat way choses qui sont des créances
croisé entre exploitants nucléaires qui
sont actuellement admise comme
provisions qui n est pas du tout là
aussi esprit la loi sur le value à sion
d'aider des dépenses sous les coups que
que les mesures que l'homme en impose et
edf ou représentés je lui ai dit que
c'était une attitude évaluation
préliminaire comme toi de nous avons pas
encore pris la décision d'aller prendre
d'essai d'ici le 30 juin
donc tu peux pas être très précis j'ai
simplement le sentiment mais voyez
utilise un terme que vous pouvez
qualifier de qualitatif
j'ai le sentiment que l'évasion de
l'ordre de 10 milliards de francs et et
le bonheur de grandeur mais je ne peux
absolument pas vous garantir que ce sera
pas 8 ou pas du doudouk est comme ça
mais l'ordre de grandeur est était et
est clairement de à mes yeux le bon puis
dernier mot sur l'europe je sais c'est
cette une discussion vous avions déjà eu
lors d'un épisode précédent ces
pavillons souvenez mais surprise il me
semble que les difficultés du contrôle
d'un contrôle européen en matière sûreté
nucléaire tient au fait que les
installations nucléaires sont son
objection pas seulement technique mais
politique
si vous avez des pays qui sont contre le
contre le nucléaire vous l'avez des
partis qui sont contre le nucléaire
à ma connaissance je n'avais pas de pays
ou de partis qui sont contre l'industrie
chimique ou l'industrie métallurgique et
ça veut donc dire que dans nombre de cas
le nucléaire est considéré comme quelque
chose
entraînant la nécessité de position
politique pour ou contre est à mes yeux
le nucléaire ressemble beaucoup aux
organismes génétiquement modifiés
c'est très frappant il ya un exemple un
secteur où
il a été pris le parti de donner du
pouvoir d'europe qui l'autorisation des
organismes génétiquement modifiés
donc pour celle peut autoriser des
semences c'est fascinant de voir comment
ça se passe et c'est fascinant de voir
combien dès qu'un pays considère que la
décision de bruxelles ne lui plaît pas
il s'attache à prendre des mesures
réglementaires pour la soyons poli
contourner la soyons là aussi plus rudes
heurté la disposition de ces noix et mon
sentiment c'est que sur des objets comme
les centaines clair ou d'un stage pour
tout à fait trouvé une situation de ce
genre
un pays considérant que faire tourner
une centrale nucléaire au contenu à
faire tourner peut tout à fait
justifiées qui n'obéissent pas du tout
une injonction supposé de bruxelles
c'est ça que j'ai en tête les alors ça
n'empêche pas du tout qu'il faille dans
l'état actuel des choses essayait de
s'harmoniser autant que possible essayer
d'être aussi cohérente possible alors
une des façons de faire a été après la
décision du conseil européen que le
cahier des charges qui a été appliquée
aux stress tests ou des versions
complètement sûreté tagai charges
uniques qui a été élaboré par une
association de chefs d'autorité ouanna
qui était approuvé par les règles et la
commission donc il ya un cahier des
charges unique
il ya des rapports nationaux dans la
majorité ils ont été faites de façon
tout à fait sérieuse et il ya un
processus de revue par les pairs de peer
review qui est actuellement en cours il
ya dix sept rapports nationaux
il ya quinze rapports de pays de l'union
européenne ya un rapport de la suisse y
un apport de l'ukraine se fait dix sept
rapports ils sont soumis une produit par
les pairs cette revue par les pairs
mobilisent pour qu'on de 100 experts et
est menée par un des commissaires
l'autorité sur tille cas française qui
s'appelle philippe jamet donc l'un des
commissaires et qui a été directeur de
la sûreté nucléaire à lier donc qui est
féru en matière internationale et cette
revue par les pairs prend les dix sept
rapports nation découpe en tranches
le sujet des régions naturelles le sujet
des pertes de fonctions sûreté le sujet
en crise se traduit pas le père en
compte
comporte une visite dans chaque pays une
ville de central et doit aboutir un
rapport du port de stress tests pardon
de ne parler franglais qui est en cours
d'élaboration et qui va être présenté à
l'esn trade commission pour créer par la
commission le 25 avril et elle doit
servir de base au rapport que la
commission va donner au conseil européen
il ya donc un processus d'harmonisation
tout à fait clair j'ajoute que ce
processus a pour but de parvenir si
possible à quelques recommandations
quatre ou cinq idées qui sur lesquels le
conseil européen peut tout à fait dire
aux différents pays et coûté creuser
plus avant l'application de ces quatre
ou cinq idées principales en tel ou tel
pays nous nous sommes par exemple très
porteurs de l'intérêt du concept noyau
dur je sais pas ça va être prêt mais
c'est typiquement quelque chose qui
serait intéressant que chaque pays
essaie d'appliquer d'appliquer chez lui
donc il ya produit la médiation qui
n'est pas extrême c'est du parc c'est du
cas par cas mais je crois que ça va ça
va dans le bon sens merci monsieur
président
c'est la partie de l'installation qui
est davantage protéger contre les
agressions typiquement ensemble de crise
bancarisés et le diesel d'ultime secours
plus sa forme d'autres choses
c'était votre numéro et laurence
rossignol monsieur le président merci
d'abord de votre propos et je voulais
vous poser quelques questions à question
la première choisir si vous partagez un
propos qu'on a entendu ici qui en fait
consisterait à dire qu' il n'y aurait
pas de durée de fonctionnement a priori
pour un équilibre réacteurs nucléaires
que c'est aux contrôles décennale qu'on
peut dire si cet équipement repart pour
dix ans et c'est la fois suivante qu'on
vérifiera si tu peux faire encore dix
ans et qu'en fin de compte n'a pas d'à
priori ce propos la s'appuie sur
l'exemple américain je crois qui est
dans un prolongement assez long est ce
que vous partagez cette analyse ça c'est
ma première question ma deuxième
question c'est concernant le bilan vous
faites de votre du rôle de votre
institution
est-ce que vous paraît possible de
garantir dans d'autres pays à la fois à
nucléaire sûre et une absence d'autorité
de sûreté indépendante
est ce que dans les pays qui refusent
une position indépendante
on peut penser que le nucléaire pourrait
néanmoins être sûr quand j'ai entendu ce
que vous avez dit heures sur la corée du
sud
je crois que la question s'est posée
à plusieurs reprises jacques à votre
sentiment à tuer ma troisième question
concerne l'étendue de vos de vos
contrôles est-ce que vous contrôlez les
installations s'agit pour y est ce que
vous vous évaluez aussi les questions de
compétence des personnels affectés au
fonctionnement des réacteurs et des
questions de sous traitance est ce que
ça rentre aussi dans le champ de votre
de votre pouvoir de contrôle et enfin
dernière question vous faites un rapport
annuel qui est un rapport annuel je
crois qui est essentiellement sur base
déclarative
non il ya donne dans chaque année les
touristes sur nucléaire publie un
récapitulatif
et c'est sur base déclarative de la part
de l'opérateur ça suppose fonctionnement
de confiance c'est ça que vous avez dit
je suis président merci monsieur pesant
d'or tu es sur la durée de
fonctionnement je je je redis que dans
l'état actuel du droit français
l'autorisation de création d'une
installation est donné sans indication
de limites quantitatives dans le temps
la station peut fonctionner aussi
longtemps qu'elle est considérée comme
sûre et nous nous elle sait nous
vérifions qu'elle est sûr d'une part pas
jours à jour par des inspections comme x
1000 milles parents parlent d'ondés
l'inspection réactive après incident et
puis pas rendez vous plus solennelle
tous les dix ans c'est la façon de faire
française c'est généralement la façon de
faire européenne
ce n'est pas de façon de faire
américaine et nous attachons essayer de
convertir les américains hallyday qu'une
révision périodique fureter tron appelle
ps et en anglais public safety review
est une bonne chose
nous avons beaucoup de mal un mot là
aussi sur le japon le japon ne
pratiquait pas les
public safety review tous les dix ans et
tout laisse penser que le réacteur
general electric les recteurs
gériatrique fukushima n'avait guère
bougé depuis l'origine je pense qu'en
france des recteurs ce genre aurait été
mis au goût du jour autant qu'il était
possible tout au moins tous les dix ans
deuxième chose sur le nous prend de
l'indépendance de l'autorité sûreté
l'indépendance de l'autorité sûreté est
quelque chose qui ce qui se construit et
qui se conquiert au cours du temps pour
l'autorité française entre sa création
en 1973 et la loi tsn qui a été voté par
l'immense majorité des partis en 2006 il
s'est écoulé 33 ans est tout à fait
clair que notre indépendance accrue au
cours du temps d'abord cru de fait dès
facto pas beaucoup sourire d'avoir reçu
beaucoup d'ordres de ministre quand nous
dépendons ministre et puis elle est
devenue des jurés par la loi tsn ça se
construit pas à pas quand je visite un
certain nombre d'autres pays tu as est
frappée de voir qu'ils sont dans les
temps intermédiaires
il ya des pays où l'autorité sûreté
peine encore à sortir de l'équivalent du
ceva ya des pays où l'autorité est
davantage évolué et qu'il ya des pays
qui paraissent matures comme comme c'est
le cas par exemple ou aux états-unis au
canada mais c'est résultat d'un long
processus est en procès depuis ce qui
n'est pas simple parce que dans beaucoup
de pays pouvoir politique considère qui
n'est pas normal de délégués à une
autorité indépendante un pouvoir
régalien ce chèque de ce type
je vous rappelle qu'en 1999 le conseil
d'état a indiqué sur un projet doit
créer une autorité indépendante le
conseil d'état indiqué au premier
ministre lionel jospin qui n'était pas
bien de songer à créer une autorité
administrative indépendante si on
domaine aussi fondamentale la sûreté
nucléaire et le premier ministre de
l'époque a jugé qu'il ne pouvait pas
passer outre qui fait que la loi n'a été
votée qu'en 2006 donc c'est un sujet
sensible et politiquement sensible je
pense qu'une évolution en ce sens la
corée du sud vient de crever
une autorité qui a vocation à être
indépendante le japon va essayer
d'améliorer situation c'est très
difficile très très difficile votre
question suivante porte sur le point de
savoir si nous contrôlons les
compétences à tous traitance oui soit
nous sommes extrêmement porteur du fait
que la sûreté nucléaire s'est pas
uniquement loin de là des questions
mécanique de béton de construction mais
que c'est fondamentalement une
compétence humaine
c'est ce que j'avais évoqué tout à leur
facteur humain socio organisationnel et
nous sommes porteurs d'une chose qui est
tout à fait fondamental souhaite jamais
eu utilisons de mauvais rumen cependant
toujours de facteurs sociaux
additionnels et humains parce que je ne
connais aucune personne qu'est pour
volonté de faire des erreurs
très souvent ces personnes fait des
erreurs ce qui a été mal formés vous
pouvez dans mauvaises conditions de
travail
c'est fondamental si j'ajoute que nous
sommes extrêmement clairement porter
aussi du fait que quand une erreur a été
commise punir la personne n'est pas la
chose à faire vous essayez de comprendre
pourquoi ça s'est fait c'est un des
sujets que l'on abordé de nouveau dans
le groupe de travail facteurs sociaux
opérationnel humain que nous allons
convoquer prochainement dans le cadre
des suites de fukushima dernier élément
vous avez évoqué un rapport annuel sur
base déclarative que je n'ai pas bien
saisi ce que vous évoquez
nous publions chaque année un rapport
annuel mais qu'est le nôtre
les réponses à vos questions à vos
interrogations de l'exploitant sont des
réponses déclaratif c'est ça que vous le
dire je crois non son signal nous
considérons que l'exploitant à se
relever quand quand comme comme nous
l'imposent ont quelque chose est patent
il doit le faire quand nous posons les
questions exploitants il doit répondre
mais à l'évidence c'est sa
responsabilité
puis à nous de voir ce que nous faisons
de sa réponse je je je je prends un
exemple avec nous publions toute ma vie
nous faisons mais l'inflexion nous
publions nos 1000 lettres de suite
l'exploitant nous répond nous publions
pas l'être de l'exploitant sur notre
site parce que nous conseillons de ses
responsabilités l'exploitant mais nous
prendrons ensuite la décision qui nous
paraissent adéquat merci du président
ronan dantec qui ne va pas faire un
exposé mais qui va poser des questions
je ne fais jamais d'exposer je pose des
questions précises parfois plusieurs ce
qui va être le cas première question
concerne ans ce prolongement des
centrales et j'ai bien noté votre mot
surfer quand on a un souci important si
jamais demain on était en situation de
conflit entre sécurité dégradé et
fourniture d'électricité edf nous
annonce aujourd'hui un investissement
d'environ 50 milliards pour prolonger le
parc actuel de 40 à 60 ans donc on a
bien compris que votre niveau
tous les dix ans vous redonner une
autorisation pour dix ans mais je
n'imagine pas et vous allez me préciser
les choses qui n'est pas d'aller retour
entre l'exploitant et vous sur les
investissements nécessaires pour obtenir
ce ce prolongement de 20 ans en terme de
sécurité donc j'aimerais que vous nous
expliquer mieux où on vous en êtes de ce
dialogue un peu comme sur les dix
milliardième vous a fourni un document
disant voilà comment les 10 milliards en
sécurité pourrait se dispatcher et nous
serions d'ailleurs tout à fait intéressé
pourra voir le document dans lequel edf
nous on n'a pas droit aux mêmes en
commission denquête tout cas si nous
pouvons avoir le document
si c'est dans les prérogatives de la
commission denquête nous en serions
ravis donc première question c'est
autour de ces 50 milliards parce que on
imagine pas qu edf investit 50 milliards
avec vous derrière vous dis demain
allez vous faire mais quand même donc
voilà comment comment cela se passe à ce
niveau la première question
deuxième question concernant le mox qui
est un questions importantes en termes
de sécurité
on dit mais peut-être que vous allez me
démentir que en termes de bombardements
des des cuves le mox est potentiellement
plus plus agressif sur la sur la cu et
pourrait aussi amener à une réaction
accéléré or quand on a une force
d'action rapide qui met quand même
quelques heures à intervenir plus le
plus la vitesse en cas de perte de
contrôle est grande plus le risque d'une
perte de contrôle définitive est très
grande en qu'est ce que le la filière
mox en termes de sécurité est un choix
raisonnable et notamment dans une
logique de de prolongement des centrales
actuelles
troisième question c'est une
interrogation par rapport à fukushima on
a quand même eu beaucoup de soucis sur
les piscines on parle toujours du coeur
en activité et on oublie souvent les
piscines pourquoi n'avez-vous pas
proposer un confinement des piscines
suite à fukushima donc là je parle
maintenant de fukushima et pas
uniquement du prolongement en vie
normale et puis c'est malheureusement
une
une actualité toujours barbare un avion
détourné qui tombe sur une piscine ça
fait quand même beaucoup de dégâts donc
on aimerait savoir comment vous voyez ce
cas de figure très très précis pourquoi
on est arrivé à la conclusion du
confinement des piscines et dernière
question très court où en est-on sûr le
père puisque vous suivez attentivement
ce dossier du contrôle commande où on
nous dit qu'il ya quand même beaucoup de
difficultés sur le contrôle-commande et
plus généralement donc on a bien vu
qu'il y avait sur la sur le gros oeuvre
un certain nombre de difficultés
est ce que demain on a encore à votre
avis
beaucoup de difficultés à venir mais
plus là sur la gestion du coeur du
système lui même
bravo monsieur dantec pour la brièveté
monsieur le président
c'est pas la question porte sur l'ailé
et 50 milliards annoncés par par edf
l'algérie s'est vraiment responsabilité
d'edf
je ne sais pas ce que course et 50
milliards qui sont hâtés hâtivement
annoncé comme destinée à prolonger la
durée de fonctionnement des réacteurs
au-delà de 30 ans comme destiné à passer
de 40 à 60 ans je ne sais pas ce que
sont ces 50 milliards par ailleurs nous
l'avons entamé un dialogue avec edf sur
la possibilité de prolonger la durée de
fonctionnement de 40 à 60 ans quand une
fois c'est le début d'un dialogue là on
dit edf il faudra vérifier la conformité
vos matériels essentiellement les cuves
et le confinement et puis par ailleurs
nous vous poserons la question des pâtes
progrès que bout et faire pour
rapprocher et les objectifs sûreté des
réacteurs existants du recteur hop et r
on est au début du dialogue
à ma connaissance nous n'avons en face
de nous aucun aucune évaluation quelle
qu'elle soit sur le manque de lui-même
mais je pense pas que l'utilisation du
mox et la moindre conséquence sur les
conditions d'intervention de la force
d'action rapide pourra peut-être en
parler plus en détail si vous voulez je
n'ai pas du tout l'impression que ce
soit l'état sur les fukushima 1 q awards
mis sur le logement du parc non sur la
cuve ya pas de conséquences non je sais
tu que s'il ya quelque chose c'est le
deuxième neuf et n'avons pas du tout là
dessus les états d'âme
on pourra en parler plus en détail sur
fukushima et les piscines est tout à
fait clair savait que les piscines de
combustible usé sont un de nos soucis
c'est un non pas qu'elle d'ailleurs je
dit l'herne là on est tendu en france le
champ des stress tests aux un sort dont
d'autres invitations dont dont
l'installation dotées de piscines et là
le problème s'est posé savoir pour nous
c'est ici une piste de confinement était
à privilégier nous avons regardé nous en
avons discuté avec l'opérateur en état
que les choses ça nous paraît pas la
piste à privilégier et nous préférons
privilégier la piste consistant à
prévenir autant qu'il est possible les
risques de
perte de refroidissement terre de perte
de perte de 1
mais là aussi si vous voulez on pourra
encore en discuter et a pris ce que nous
prenions lac est conforme à celle que
prennent la plupart de nos collègues que
faisait la question porte sur le
contrôle commande de p r nous allons
publier sous quelques jours
notre position sur le contrôle commande
de ppr qui consisterait à dire que nous
considérons que les réserves que nous
l'avons posée en octobre 2009 en octobre
2009 sont levés une lettre va essayer
edf d'ici quelques jours et note
d'information va être diffusé j'ajoute
que ceux ci aient consécutive un certain
nombre de contacts avec nos homologues
qui sont en charge du contrôle de la
construction de paix en chine en
finlande est possible paisiblement
pendant les 2 versions possibles ou au
royaume uni mais c'est monsieur le
président en m'excusant prévenir et
cherche puisqu'il avait posé la question
avant jean claude lenoir
bien merci free président revenus entre
air de bord rapidement sur le rôle de
l'asn je vais vous dire ici monsieur
lacoste que la façon dont l'asn exerce
son autorité et une véritable assurance
qui est apportée à ce qu'ils croient
nucléaire il n'y a pas d'autorité sûreté
nucléaire au monde qui est l'autorité
vous avez je le dis car c'est souvent
une façon de répondre à ceux qui très
légitimement d'ailleurs pose des
questions sur la fiabilité du nucléaire
une chose est sûre c'est que le
nucléaire n'est pas entre les mains des
politiques même si vous devez soulever
un problème qui n'est pas sans nous
interroger
c'est vraiment une autorité qui s'est
affirmé depuis 2006 alors revenant très
rapidement sur des questions assez
mineur jaurès où le savoir comment sont
déclenchées les contrôles lorsqu'il ya
l'incident les entrées nucléaire c'est
une déclaration de l'opérateur qui en
fut ou fait intervenir lorsqu'il y a des
communications de la part de l'opérateur
10 ans il ya eu un incident niveau 1
niveau 2 en fait c'est après que vous
l'ayez vous même vérifier comment ça se
passe lorsqu'un incident se produit
deuxièmement ces cancers d actifs d rt
le chemin un peu troublé parce que j'ai
le sentiment que vous raisonner par
rapport la lys à sion quitté précédente
à celle de 2006 concernant la structure
d'edf dire que les au moment où situez
vous semble ignorer que
ensuite les réseaux de notamment de
transport sont devenus filiale à 100%
d'edf
vous avez le sentiment en déclarant ce
que vous avez dit à l'heure que ce sont
des planètes un peu éloigné d'edf bon je
vais simplement avoir votre réponse sur
sur ce point alors concernant le p r
j'aurais souhaité vérifier auprès de
vous que vous avez des contacts avec
olkiluoto en finlande et taishan en
chine qui sont donc les deux autres
européennes qui sont d'ailleurs en
construction à ce qu'ils aient une
coopération internationale sur la façon
dont on construit les récepteurs du type
père en dire dans différents pays et
même comment les choses peuvent se
passer
tandis dans les années qui viennent pour
qui les comparaisons de fait à deux mois
la semaine dernière nous avons entendu
une personne qui a une certaine autorité
sur ces questions monsieur champsaur
nous nous affirmait que nous étions en
situation de surcapacité nucléaire que
la question d'augmenter les capacités
d'ici à 15 ans ne se posait pas alors
c'est pas votre rôle en évaluer les
besoins de la france en termes de
capacité de production d'origine
nucléaire il parlait bien d'origine
nucléaire
néanmoins on ne peut pas déconnecter
complètement votre rôle de
l'appréciation qui est fait notamment
lorsque vous avez soulevé la question
très pertinente du conflit entre un
problème qui se pose sur un réacteur et
les problèmes d'approvisionnement
bon ça veut bien dire qu'aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas dans le cas de la scène
ignoré la question de la capacité
production et donc des besoins en
électricité
enfin dernière question est ce que vous
avez j'ai pas annoncés avant qu'il y
avait une van lent c'est très court quel
est votre avis sur fessenheim c'est à
dire sur les précautions à prendre par
rapport au sous-sol ses terres à ce que
vous avez j'imagine xav analysons qu'une
demande simplement votre avis
c'est pas danger reprendre la question
dans l'ordre le premier pas je suis
sensible aux louanges exprimé par
monsieur noir sur la scène simplement le
rapporteur est bien notée te dire que je
disais j'étais d'un confortable sur le
sujet et et je vous prie de croire que
compte tenu des responsabilités qui sont
les nôtres nous ne sommes pas bardé de
certitudes tranquilles une autorité de
sûreté qui commence à croire qu'elle est
bonne et sûrement en train de devenir
mauvaise ça va être tout à fait
fondamentale et si vraiment le type des
changes que nous avons avec nos
homologues nous les changeons plutôt des
telle interrogation et la nécessité de
travailler que qu'autre chose
le deuxième point que soulevait par
monsieur noir les déclarations ainsi
dans leur déclaration incidents sont dus
obligatoire panda par la loi nous y
veillons quand l'incident le mérite nous
faisons l'inspection et nous ne désirons
pas à sanctionner quand c'est pas le cas
un exemple sur la tp ou d'ateliers
traitement du plutonium à cadarache le
sénat déclare avec beaucoup de retard en
incitant qui était un incident sérieux
nous avons dressé pv nous avons envoyé
le sait au tribunal et le ca vient
d'être condamné par le tribunal à
marseille nous ne perdons payantes ont
pas avec la nécessité de déclaré
l'incident en temps utile ce qui est
fondamental c'est la base du retour
d'expérience c'est la base de
l'amélioration se bat la sûreté sur les
titres rte
suite rte est un exemple d'aider des
points qui ont été relevé par nous et
qui ont été reliés par la cour c'est à
dire on est en train pampa de s'éloigner
de l'esprit de la loi
rte n'a sûrement pas l'exemple le plus
criant métivet quand on voit que les
charges futures du sahara sont couvertes
par des titres d'areva et par des
créances sur l'état on est aux antipodes
de ce que vous décevoir mais je n'ai pas
ça c'est pas ce n'est pas mon domaine
strict de compétences mais nous
partageons ce switch en dessous si par
peur qu'un beau jour on soit incapable
de financer l'ensemble l'opération
de démantèlement et le traitement des
déchets vous avez ensuite posé le
problème de la du partage
internationales en matière de sûreté du
réacteur p r ça se fait via un club qui
a été fondée par une dizaine d'autorités
de sûreté qui s'appelle m2p
multinationales des line l'évaluation de
programmes qui étaient fondés en fait
par l'autorité américaine et l'autorité
française via les groupes de travail
thématiques
je suis en contrôle commande sur la
l'inspection a pris goût de travail par
type de réacteur est en partie gain de
cause le travail sur directeur repères
et c'est là que nous discutons avec nos
collègues américains chinois
britanniques finlandais et canadiens
d'un certain nombre de sujets de pair
alors soit contrôle commande chez soi
dans groupe ppr soit dans le groupe
contrôle commande
mais c'est là que nous avons échangé
pour aboutir à la conclusion que j'ai
indiqué en réponse à votre question
ça marche les différentes autorités
apportent plus ou moins prennent plus ou
moins mais ça ça marche sur phénomène de
surcapacités duclair n'avons pas
vocation à ne soit pas équipé pour
porter un jugement de leurs capacités ou
surcapacité syndicats selon notre souci
sme il faut éviter de nous trouver
ensuite un phénomène de sous capacités
ou de capacité limite entraînant un
conflit extrêmement difficile à traiter
entre sécurité et et approvisionnement
et puis dernier point sur fessenheim
souhaite surfer l'allemagne notre
position n'a n'a pas évolué ces
dernières semaines nous avons pris
position sur fessenheim deux fois ont
pris position sur fessenheim 1 au terme
de la troisième révision décennale dit
des saloperies pollution juillet 2011 et
là nous avons des eaux terme cette
révision nous impôts long de mémoire une
trentaine de prescription
quand une quarantaine de prescription
les deux principales étant
épaississement du radier leurs adieux de
fessenheim été nettement plus on les
paie que lui les autres centrales pour
des raisons historiques
et puis deuxièmement mise en place a
fait sa noble une source alternative de
refroidissement des siens super source
principale c'est ça qu'on a imposé en
juillet sur ces deux mesures là on avait
dit à fessenheim 1 vous nous présenter
un dossier pour la fin de l'année le
dossier a été présenté
nous sommes en train d'examiner cette
première fois qu'on a regardé fixement
et puis on a regardé fessenheim outils
de la procédure fukushima donc la
première sous couche humain on a imposé
un ensemble de choses nouvelles comme le
noyau dur des halles ultime secours sans
de gestion de crise comme crise et comme
forme d'action rapide ça s'applique à
toute centrale de fessenheim toumi les
mesures spécifiques à foucault à
fessenheim demeure applicable a fait son
âme ici rajoute les mesures générales
applicables à tous les centrales d'edf
monsieur le président mes recherches si
monsieur président
voilà ça la première vous avez parlé à
l'instant de cadarache donc à une
déclaration qui se fait vous d'un
incident et moi ce que je souhaiterais
savoir c'est justement suite un incident
et de la même façon fessenheim vous
dites qu'il ya des préconisations quelle
force vous avez pour que vos
préconisations se transforme en
réalisation c'est à dire 'est-ce que
vous suivez ce qui a suivi est ce qu'il
ya des délais j'avoue je ne sais pas
comment vous fonctionnez pour après
l'incident
ma deuxième question est est ce que
votre avis monsieur le président
n'est-il pas temps d'apprendre à des
construire une centrale nucléaire
je dis ça très tranquillement en dehors
de toute polémique c'est à dire bientôt
beaucoup de nos centrales vont arriver
presque à terme de leur temps de
fonctionnement raisonnable et afin qu'on
ne soit pas pris par le temps j'ai envie
de demander de vous demander votre
sentiment sur une déconstruction
tranquille qui nous qui ferait écoles et
qui serait utile pour la suite
ma troisième question l'asn avait émis
un avis en effet le 3 janvier 2012 en
disant que vous estimiez que le facteur
humain était l'un des piliers de sûreté
nucléaire de la sûreté dans les
centrales
or il y a plus de 30000 salariés de
sous-traitants
vous dites que vous connaissez ou que
vous surveillez bien sûr leurs
compétences ne serait-il pas temps là
aussi davos afin d'avoir des
préconisations pour limiter la sous
traitance de façon assez drastiques
notamment dans les dents le coeur enfin
dans le coeur du métier nucléaire j'ai
envie de dire par périphérique
il semble que ces derniers temps mais je
suis honteux pas aussi mis à former que
vous bien sur une inflation de la sous
traitance peut-être à terme dangereuse à
la fois pour ses salariés mais aussi
pour les fonctionnement des centrales
est la dernière question porte
la même façon sur les les composants par
exemple je sais pas sous votre couvert
mais il me semble que les composants de
la turbine de le père de flamanville de
flamanville sont fabriqués dans 11 pays
différents
peut-être pourquoi ne serait-il pas
fabriqué en france pour une meilleure
sûreté justement un meilleur contrôle de
ses pièces n'est-il pas bon non plus
d'avoir une préconisation forte de faire
en sorte que ces pièces puissent être
fabriqués en france et a semblé aussi
ici en france comme elles le sont merci
mes recherches monsieur le président
c'est la première chose c'est ça la
question porte sur les préconisations
dans préconisation est un mot inconnu
chez nous nous prenons des décisions et
qui sont des décisions comminatoire
applicable et et dont nous vérifions
l'application avec avec des délais si je
prends les glandes de l'atp eu quand
nous avons appris cette non déclaration
d'un incident nous avons suspendu le
fonctionnement de la tpu a suspendu le
démantèlement bud des différentes
cellules atpu nous les avons avons
soumis à d'autres choses que à notre
autorisation de redémarrage tangible
nous devons surveiller d'extrêmement
près les choses en vérifiant que les
installations étaient remises en état
sûr est que le plutonium un excédent
était correctement traités encore une
fois nous fonctionnons autorités c'est
pas un as un vent cependant nous prenons
des sillons sont pas des préconisations
l'exploitant n'a pas le choix sur le
deuxième paquet à des constructions
c'est en france nous n'avons pas
l'habitude de décompte wade s'installe
ceux des centrales nucléaires il ya déjà
eu des de la décontraction d'autres
installations nucléaires
le centre de fontenay
de qui tu seras est en cours de
démantèlement le démantèlement du centre
du cea de grenoble est pratiquement
achevée donc il ya des expériences de
les constructions mais nous poussons
autant que possible pour avoir des
l'exemple des constructions en vraie
grandeur de centrales c'est pour ça que
nous avions poussé edf a été monté aussi
vite que possible brennilis panis a
connu un certain nombre d'aléas en
particulier juridique
c'est pour ça que nous poussons les
démantèlements aussi vite que possible
la centrale de choses
ah c'est pour ça que nous poussons aussi
vite que possible démantèlement des
réacteurs le fuyait rue adjugée pour
avoir d'expérience alors vous direz
c'est l'expérience porte que des types
de réacteurs qui correspond pas à la
filière actuelle mais au moins ils
permettent de rassembler expérience et
de faire la comparaison avec des pays
étrangers
mais pour nous il est tout à fait
fondamental de sortir des oiseaux
théorique pour avoir les évaluations en
vraie grandeur composent le président
mireille nous sommes allés voir la
déconstruction de brennilis en bretagne
vendredi prochain notre reporter va voir
show la déconstruction de choses
ah si jamais votre emploi du temps vous
permet allez-y ça vaut la peine c'est
intéressant parce que ce sont les deux
centrales qui sont déjà un niveau 50 %
de déconstruction
sur le troisième point sur les facteurs
sociaux initialement une partageons tout
à fait le sentiment que que c'est tout à
fait fondamental est que quand on parle
uniquement des composants d'une
installation
on oublie que cette installation est
gérée et opéré par par des gens adorent
actuellement au nord de grandeur il ya
vingt mille personnes d'edf qui
travaillent sont trahis havas mis sous
traitants c'est l'ordre de grandeur
les conditions de travail des sous
traitants sont un de nos soucis alors
c'est un chantier qu'on va ouvrir
on l'annoncé d'ici l'été avec la
participation dans son les parties
prenantes et syndicats j'ai eu que
d'ores et déjà avons pris une
disposition dans un arrêté
l'installation qui a de base qui a été
signé le 9 février directement
consécutif à fukushima qui est obligé
edf assurer la surveillance directe des
l'opération sous traiter quand elle
touche d'éléments importants poids
sûreté mais c'était que le premier
élément de l'ensemble de ce que nous
souhaitons déroulé enfin la turbine la
turbine qui est pas chez nous cc c'est
un équipement classique il peut y avoir
multitude sous traitants que je peux
vous garantir c'est que quand il s'agit
de dossiers touchant au nucléaire nous
regardons de très près et en particulier
quand y'a de sous traitance à l'étranger
nous allons vérifier sur place ce qui se
passe j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure c'est
que à l'occasion de la fabrication sur 9
i roll d'un pressuriseur par un sous
traitant italien de la firme n'en groupe
nous avions arrêté la fabrication il est
bien obligé areva a déclassé une partie
des des fournitures dont on surveille de
très près je devrais le savoir ces
turbines alstom non je devrais le savoir
celui turbines alstom pour flamanville
non mais je dois sans doute de savoir
aussi mais je ne sais pas merci monsieur
président pu écouter je vous remercie
vraiment pour la précision de toutes vos
réponses nous avons beaucoup apprécié et
je suis sûr que votre audition fera
poids
et autorité dans notre le futur rapport
que notre rapporteur rédigera et je vous
en remercie infiniment me permettez vous
de dire monsieur présent que vraiment
très profondément
l'asn est à disposition du parlement
quel que soit le sujet traité quelle que
soit la forme plus ou moins solennelle à
des conditions dans lesquelles ils à
l'instigation est menée j'ai beaucoup
apprécié notre introduction et le
président du groupe énergie que je suis
par ailleurs abusera peut-être de sa à
la rentrée parlementaire c'est-à-dire à
l'automne prochain
merci beaucoup
voilà pour cette audition d'andré claude
lacoste le président de l'asn autorité
de sûreté nucléaire si vous souhaitez la
revoir notre site internet
publicsenat.fr
à suivre l'émission politique de la
rédaction preuve par 3 qui reçoit ce
soir nathalie arthaud candidate de lutte
ouvrière à l'élection présidentielle
très belle soirée à tous